how's it go fresman is beautiful welcome
to another oculus rift video today you
and I girl we're gonna play boy whatever
we're gonna play some Huckle is ripped
this time a horror game and we both know
how that went last time
but yeah I've decided to man up so
without any more introduction let's do
this press listen closely now oh okay
I'm listening
see those glowing specks of light I see
them those are soul shots
okay fragments of spirit scattered
through the halls of this little maze
well yeah over more and the first puzzle
piece will be ready
Oh first one what you're not alone ah
can I'm stir in here a man stay do
something I plucked from your worst
nightmare oh not the Miley Cyrus
twerking not Miley Cyrus do I can you
stop alright oh god I hear I swear to
God all right so I'm cold this feels
like pac-man it's this pac-man nice
painting I don't get suspected this is
really cool with the the VR it's not
really scary though BAE what am i what
are you gonna do about it don't nap nap
nap nom nom nom nom nom
what is he here are you talking about is
she on my side does it seem like it oh
god I don't like this is scaring me what
if I run into it I don't like that ah
it's getting so dark where am I
I got I hear something on the right I
don't know what it is but I don't want
to loud oh gotta tell me that
display this ginormous half-shut ah
what boy saw something I saw something I
don't know it
ah what the [ __ ] is that what is that
what is that oh there's twice of - oh
are you milking my tits right [ __ ] ah
why need oh god yes shut up shut your
[ __ ] mouth huh you my jester
[ __ ] you yeah yeah she's so mean god I'm
trying to keep track of so many things
at once
oh boy I sure wish this game was larger
because oh [ __ ] me please don't be there
please the oh thank god I'll share your
batch mr Mackey dan your face mr. monkey
that's right bro high five I don't know
where you are so I'm just gonna hop 5
everywhere see rag come on let's be
honest I was pretty amazing that was the
demo oh that was a quick one wasn't it
alright let's play some more I don't
want to leave you bros hanging just a
few minutes of a video this one is a
chair in a room sure it spins in the air
kilos raft or if you're watching
PewDiePie play with the oculus way
well alright so I am sitting on a chair
in a room amazing take a look around and
make a set familiar with your
surroundings body found to be hoax
big bones found in hoax great what the
[ __ ] does that mean someone's gonna come
through that door someone better not
come through that door
hello no I didn't want another horror
game I wanted a fun nice one oh oh oh no
oh no oh hello hello someone out there
no don't play why am I doing this
no I don't lighten the fleas please
please leave
thank you someone entered that room
no [ __ ] way no [ __ ] way
it wasn't me I don't know what happened
but it wasn't me
please blunder evidence oh god what's
going on here oh god no no no no Oh what
the [ __ ]
um no I'm not your debt okay then that's
a nice deli puff
Oh dumpling thing fun oh my god don't do
that again
no not crying girls oh what the
okay me every time every goddamn time is
it that necessary
[ __ ] man
I don't want no I'm sorry I can't do
more I'm sorry thank you for liking this
video it's all I can do I swear to God
brofist bros i'll see you in the next
one